c'est suffisamment rare pour être
souligné le ministre de l'Intérieur
obligé de se justifier hier sur BFM TV
sur le limoge de la préfète
d'Indre-et-Loire Gérald Darmanin qui a
dénoncé les mensonges sur les raisons de
son éviction ajoutant que les
représentants de la République devaient
être inattaquable et respectable
allusion en relation difficile que Marie
lajusse entretenait avec certains élus
locaux
et c'est dans ce contexte que sont
remplaçant a pris aujourd'hui ses
fonctions ancien militaires avant de
rejoindre la préfectorale Patrice Latron
a dévoilé ses priorités devant la presse
Hélène chapelet
c'est lui le nouveau représentant de
l'État en Indre-et-Loire Patrice Latron
a officiellement pris ses fonctions ce
lundi 2 janvier à 61 ans c'est sa
troisième nomination en tant que préfet
comme le veut la tradition il a déposé
une gerbe de fleurs devant le monument
aux morts de Tours une cérémonie en
présence des députés sénateurs et
représentants politiques du département
l'occasion aussi pour l'ancien directeur
de cabinet de la ministre chargé de la
mémoire et des anciens combattants de
faire la connaissance des portes drapeau
locaux
c'est l'occasion de rappeler aux invités
à la population le
souvenir de ceux qui ont laissé leur vie
pour défendre nos libertés protéger nos
familles notre drapeau notre pays et
donc c'est comme ça que tous les préfets
partout en France prennent leur fonction
et pour son premier jour le nouveau
préfet a décidé de rencontrer la presse
impossible alors de ne pas l'interroger
sur le départ précipité de sa
prédécesseur Marie lajusse et sur le DA
vincib qui serait au cœur de la
polémique un projet scientifique à 15
millions d'euros qui pourraient voir le
jour à Rosny j'ai vu ce matin au
monument aux morts je crois qu'il y
avait le maire de Rosny
qui a dit il faut qu'on se voit je vais
dire on va se voir bien entendu
voilà donc je ne prends aucune position
sur ce projet je redis le représentant
de l'État c'est l'application de la loi
et c'est aussi trouver un chemin pour
aider à porter des projets structurants
aux côtés des élus
parfois on dit non parfois on dit oui on
verra autre gros dossier à gérer les
trois projets de par éolien tous
contestés ou encore la crise des
urgences mardi soir le préfet ira
d'ailleurs à la rencontre des soignants
mais cette fois-ci sans la presse